we played gta with the chaos mod and you
guys loved it and since you liked it so
much we custom-made it for minecraft
and while all the chaos is going down we
have to beat the ender dragon in under
two hours or we collectively will have
to eat an onion that's disgusting
servers start the chaos mod
tnt
[Applause]
why is there tnt jeez louise
yep this is fun this is fun i died
basically random weird things are
happening every two minutes we have two
hours to kill the ender dragon and if we
don't we eat an onion carl what are we
doing collecting wood yeah let's get
some wood let's get some food is going
to be the most important part you need
wood i'll get some wood i'm getting wood
as well
swap swap up oh i switched who'd i
switch with hey get away from there you
switch with me chris get away well that
wasn't too bad of a chaos carl what do
we need kill animals even horses um
yeah even horses you don't say why not
right i oh sheep i'm gonna murder you
all right i'm gonna build a chest oh
yeah dude
oh god asteroid wait where is that
oh my god it hurled towards me
creeper
oh
man
it's been 10 minutes we have an hour and
50 minutes left to beat the game or
onion we nom nom on some onions
oh my gosh there's zombies everywhere
now
he has a helmet i guess i picked a good
place to be during this you guys have
fun with that oh wait carl carl we could
trap him
waterfall water no the enderman oh i've
i'm covered in water oh they're gonna
climb they're gonna climb they're gonna
climb oh wait they turned into water
zombies i'm getting shot by everything
why did i come out of my hole wait the
water trapped them all into one little
spot yeah i would just leave them there
i have two arrows i also have two arrows
put them together how many do we have
two no four
random two oh
where am oh i'm not that far away
where am i all right i'm gonna start a
clock so i started a stopwatch i'll give
you guys a heads up before the next one
oh oh oh no it's coming for me oh my god
what is that
the chickens are okay randall blocked oh
no stop what is going on
how am i not supposed to die
oh no it ruined the lava portal what is
this wait do we keep all this now
wait oh my gosh this is a good thing i
mean hey sometimes it's chaos and
sometimes it's chaos but good how do i
get out of this mess oh my god
a block of diamond wait this is actually
kind of useful oh another block of
diamond what a chaos was supposed to
happen 19 seconds ago fire by night oh
no no it's burning all this stuff thank
god the water's still here i'm on fire
no no i don't want that i don't want
that get me out of here get me out of
here i literally just got rid of all the
water yo why aren't all the boys wearing
ender heads gentlemen with massive heads
we need to start being more strategic no
who is gonna go get blaze rods and who's
gonna go get into pearls i'll get under
pearls i know a quick way to do it oh
here carl i know the easiest way
there's one i'm gonna go chris taylor
you go with carl all right jim jam let's
go get blaze where's some of that
diamond where's some of that diamond i
need to pick i'll give you my diamond
pick carl if you say i'm the coolest
person you've ever met i'm the coolest
person you've ever met i hate you no
hunger
oh god i'm hungry just stop starving why
doesn't everyone do that
jimmy you want to do the honors light
that puppy all right let's go chris
portal is made boys portal is made no
lion uh we need a flint and steel at the
right we're going we're gonna have to
eat an onion i don't want to eat an
onion
i landed in water oh i landed in water
as well guys it's been 30 minutes we
gotta hurry up okay we gotta make the
nether portal let's go everyone get in
the nether we gotta beat the game we're
eating an onion i'm not eating an onion
let's go perfect so if anybody has a
pickaxe either iron oh god fire oh god
the fire's not going to go away the fire
don't use water it's not worth it it
doesn't work you're the only one on fire
oh god a wizard wait why did a wither
spawn it's on me
you got this i believe in you yeah just
solo the wither
oh look it's right there i can see it oh
god it noticed me ow why is it bullying
me
waterfall oh wait look at all the
obsidian that we're probably about to
create oh this is going to make
traversing the nether actually way
easier
oh no oh no oh i'm suffocating i'm
suffocating get off of me
oh he's trying to kill me get up what
are we supposed to do oh god
ow oh that couldn't happened at a
literally worse time that was the worst
i hate chaos mode i'm just oh no
who did i swap with are you stuck in a
bunch of random blocks yes oh stop with
me
all right well carl good luck finding a
stronghold well you guys look for a
stronghold i would do anything to just
not be getting absolutely butt bullied
by these blocks hey i see a stronghold
oh there it is oh there's an ash where
is it at can the asteroids come into the
nether want to just bust through the
ceiling
trailer stop saying things i think it
can hear us hey
i found some children to trade with all
right to the stronghold guys we are
closing in on almost an hour oh here i
got it i got armor let me do it maybe we
can both do it
no
glue
oh no this is a bad time for glue
trading me gravel so this is gonna be a
while hey
i got three oh you guys are gonna
freaking love me i'm not even gonna tell
you what i just got okay i'll tell you i
got 59 arrows whoa carl you were right i
do love you now
oh no
why
it put me on the roof it put me on the
roof what are we supposed to do it put
me on the roof oh a trainer jimmy what
are we supposed to do we're stuck up
here random blocks oh oh oh wait run
around run around while you're doing it
run around while you're doing it run
around oh my gosh i'm out i'm out i'm
out go go go go go go go go wait chris
do you have enough blaze rods no i only
have nine no we gotta find another
fortress another fortress
well now i just broke my last pickaxe
guess i'm hand digging
asteroid no no way oh why
why
oh
okay
all right well there we go i guess now
we can get down why did it come for us i
have enough stuff to make another portal
we can do it boom light it hey let's go
who knows where we'll end up we're
heading back to the real world we're no
longer stuck on the roof we have less
than an hour remaining well this is a
swamp we were near swamps right
no
no
all right we all just gotta meet back up
guys we don't have ender pearls anymore
again i lost my gold and i'm not even
where the heck am i what i have to do
just mine gold and like throw it in
their pit throw it into that pit with
the guy
come by
wait wait you guys all came to me wait
carl's gold trading camp is over here
yes
yes i was so close to the portal and now
i'm back here no no this is good i
promise we're in a good spot right now
if we don't get like swapped again or
nothing like that happened why would you
say that now it's gonna happen no chance
it'll happen again oh my god we were 40
feet away from it wow i found it thanks
hey look at this
we did it we're back on the overworld
no
i hate you
i hate you i just threw the gold again
it combined us again i know we are all
distraught and i know we're suffering ah
30 minutes until we have to eat an onion
if we don't beat the game so gentlemen
are we gonna get our crap together are
we gonna eat a raw onion that sucks
probably the onion would you want to try
first yeah
yeah
all right everyone look for indies oh
enderman enderman enderman enderman
yeah baby he jumped to poorly dropped
the poorly oh i got anvil wait wait wait
wait wait guys guys guys guys yeah i
have an enderman spawner over here i'm
pretty sure yes we getting eyes baby how
many do we have how many do we have i
have six ender pearls on me give me all
your pearls i i dropped mine oh did you
oh oh no i'm in water but i'm on fire
they may replace the water with fire if
all that burnt up chris i would cry
don't worry guys i saved it all i still
guys we literally have 15 minutes okay
here i'm giving them to carl where's
carl carl we got to win i don't want to
eat an onion okay okay okay here's what
we're gonna do i know how this works
throw it it went that way that means
it'll go this way for fourteen hundred
blocks at least okay all right let's go
hurry hurry hurry
boys i hit a salmon
oh oh no there's an earthquake no stop
stop stop stop stop oh you're so lucky
there was water there i'm still running
no chaos can get in my way all right go
go go go go go nine minutes and 13
seconds can we beat the ender dragon in
nine minutes yeah yeah technically oh a
village wait no we can we can absolutely
just get the beds in the village and
move on oh this is so good we can do it
all right i got two okay i'm getting on
this tree and throwing it are you doing
it i'm throwing it right here i'm ready
ready ready throw it throw it oh yes yes
we passed it and it didn't break either
wait guys i found it i found it i found
it i found it okay right here right here
dig down dig down dig down dig down dig
down carl we believe in you you're our
minecraft champion go i kind of just
took a step oh here it is you're about
to die
no
did you die yeah you guys got like two
minutes to beat the game oh i found it
four no way we got five go in go in go
in oh wait are we going yeah throw me
the beds throw me your beds throw me
your beds jimmy had the beds and he died
i'm blown away devastated guys guys we
lost we're here come on let us try we
lost we have to eat an onion gentlemen
since we failed we must take bites of
onions three
two
one let's do this
oh
i hope you guys are happy hit the
subscribe button